hello I'm David Newman and when I served
as NASA deputy administrator that's the
number two I became very familiar with
our Earth observing satellites which
tell us about the vital signs of our
planet which I call spaceship earth eyes
on Earth from this global perspective
I saw warming temperatures melting ice
intensifying natural disasters climate
change is real and if we're going to
solve climate change the moonshot of our
generation we need everyone on board
that's why with the support of the MIT
Portugal program a partners and I
started earth DNA data into action for
the earth we want to unite the whole
world and creating a sustainable
relationship between humans and nature
and we're so happy to have you with us
you'll be our astronauts traveling to
places we could never reach by ourselves
and will be your Mission Control
providing you with the tools and
guidance you need to make an impact at
the schools around you you'll teach
students students will teach families
and families will demand action with
your help we can reach a destination a
world that works for a hundred percent
of humanity without ecological offense
we're ready for lift up and we're
thrilled to have you on board so let's
get started
three two one launch
you
you